here at home thousands of nevadans could
be forced to leave their homes in the
near future
as the clock winds down on the statewide
eviction moratorium
thanks for joining us tonight at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
many nevadans have lost jobs or income
because of the covet pandemic
making it really difficult to pay rent
orc omana joins us live with more
on what help is available to those in
need orca
well brian and denise governor sisalak
extended nevada's eviction moratorium
back at the beginning of september but
now in just over a week
on october 15th landlords can start
kicking tenants
out of their apartments or homes if they
don't pay rent
there is help available and experts
encourage everyone to act fast
it's very scary afraid of the future
thousands of nevadans struggling to pay
rent amid the coven 19 pandemic have
just days until the statewide moratorium
on evictions ends on october 15.
it's very stressful and it's always in
the back of my head but
while that's there i have to make sure
that i'm going to work and
take care of my family new data shows
more than 10 percent of las vegas missed
their rent payments last month
our city seeing the largest jump in
non-paying tenants from this time last
year compared to other metro areas
i feel like i'm in quicksand and i'm
constantly trying to claw out of the
quicksand and the more that i clog the
deeper i'm going
we are here for you the legal aid center
of southern nevada tells me those in
need should contact these local agencies
involved with housing assistance
programs but there's also the cdc
moratorium which lasts through the end
of the year
tenants must meet five requirements
including using best efforts to try and
get
help and make partial payments those who
qualify must fill out this declaration
form
they shouldn't wait if they're also
believe they are covered tenants under
the cdc order
they should review the declaration if
they meet all the criteria
sign it and provide it to their landlord
at any time much needed help during
serious uncertainty
we're just trying to catch up to
everything
now for more information about the cdc
moratorium including all the criteria
you have to meet
in order to get that help head to our
website eight news now dot com
reporting live in las vegas tonight orco
mana 8 news now